hello everyone this is Peter here on the
front lines in alsoo Blanco Ukraine
reaching out to you all wanted to
connect and let you know what's going on
with a show right now we shot what two
episodes so far we have four or five
more coming that's a great really cool
content out here this experiences like
far surpass anything I could have ever
imagined a lot of growth in this a lot
of learning I wanted to show you
creating audience you know this outside
perspective and also this American or
western audience not by getting super
out of your comfort zone like removing
everything you can learn a ton and I
feel like I've learned a lot from this
family and Ukrainian countryside and I'm
not going to say it's been easy there's
definitely been some moments much
challenge especially right now I'm sick
I'm pretty sick it's hot you taught this
house there's no escaping that obviously
I can't I'm out of my language for the
most part we got this this is the this
is the footage that gets out every week
so this goes to my editor in Kiev who's
doing these great edits sometimes the
post takes longer than we want
this is the Steadicam this is the device
that makes these very much cinematic
smooth shots that will have way more ax
this is Mark's little little bear on the
front of it and why is it here you might
ask because in a moment of despair this
morning I had to make some humor out of
it because we don't find a camera right
now the camera fell out of my pocket
last night in the back of the cab coming
back from redonk
if any of you know of a cabbie with a
new iPhone 7 + walking around with ants
please contact me so it's like camera
that would be great to get that we have
a plan B that we're getting another
camera coming down here tomorrow from
Keith so the show will go on a few
updates we have an episode coming out
most likely at the end of this week
these setbacks would put us back a
little bit and then two episodes is one
of me selling cuckoo Louisa and burn
dolls which is quite interesting because
it will be ending when mm sort of
unexpectedly and well you'll see and
thank you all thank you all for all the
comments the the cool comments that
support it's definitely helped me ride
through these these low points that in
this little girl here who says she's
amazing so yeah you know I come back
from a bike ride or something I'm
burning hot and she puts a smile on and
totally changes my mood so thank you for
all the support and the negative
comments tune that's all part of it and
I'm cool with that so thank you for
everything all of you I'm going to keep
on doing my best to get this story is
very pure simple story I'm trying to get
it in the its most real form and I feel
like it's a story that needs to be told
with that said more to come thank you so
much
to be continued bye bye